[Music]
all right let's go to ethan in chinatown
what's up ethan
hey dr john how are you i'm good my
brother what's going on with you
uh not much a little nervous sorry i've
never done anything like this before so
hey listen
i'm
i'm terrible at this and so when people
hear it they'll be like who is that guy
and they're talking about me about you
so you're good to go man so what's up
okay good to know uh so um
i am a first responder uh in chicago
what's your gig man and
i'm a police officer excellent um yep
you're a typical b-cop
i'm grateful for you man thank you
thank you sir appreciate it um so
i the reason i'm calling guess is
because over the past
i don't know maybe like a year or so
i've been feeling a lot of like
ups and downs they're
much more defined to a point where like
i've
like i've noticed it um
and uh i guess
the past month um i guess now my
ex-girlfriend uh caught me uh cheating
on her
and uh so obviously that absolutely did
not help whatsoever with my situation
and actually made it worse
and uh so it made me reflect a lot about
you know everything that's been going on
and one thing that i definitely notice
about myself is the pattern that i
seem to always cheat on every
relationship that i'm on since since 20.
i'm now 37 and so
i've only had like you know five major
relationships but it seems like
i find one i'm really into them
feels great i feel like i'm in love with
them and then
somewhere along the line i cheat and
eventually i
i feel like i no longer want to be there
but
then i don't want to break it off and
and i guess i just make things worse so
like they can just leave me yeah and so
i've never been caught this was actually
the first time
and uh
so it like say it made me feel worse for
the fact that i i hurt her so bad um so
i just like said it just seems like
everything is just like collapsing
around me and it's just like
trying to find a way out and reason like
why do i keep doing knowing that i know
it's wrong why do i keep doing stuff
like this and you know i guess you know
like as you really know i i've heard you
mention that your father was a police
officer you know that the job is
stressing i i didn't realize like i
always thought like well it's not a big
deal i see this stuff or whatever move
on but all of a sudden things are just
kind of like coming back to me and i'm
like why is this
why am i thinking about this uh scenario
or that event and yeah i just yeah sorry
hey man that's good i appreciate that so
number one thanks for your honesty uh it
takes a lot of courage number two
um
you 37 so how long you been in
uh i've been in total uh
going on 90 years now okay so you're
almost a decade and you know as well as
i do that culture
is heavy on keep your mouth shut and do
your job right so the fact that you made
this call
is an act of
bravery
that
unfortunately many of your colleagues
don't have the courage to summon so um
um i'm proud of you there okay so you've
presented two different issues that may
intertwine here and there but but let's
separate them a little bit okay
okay one of these is
to quote the old vanderkult book
the body keeps the score
and
there's only so long you can work the
beat
and for most people
in our country probably in the world
they have no idea
what's going on in their neighborhoods
after hours right right no zero none
and have no idea that guy they see out
mowing the yard had the cops called on
him at 2 am by his girlfriend because he
was beating her like they have no idea
the dead body and the in the
uh the emmy shows up at 3 30 in the
morning and nobody even knows what
happened right and so and you do that
all day
every day day after day after day after
day and you have to show up to a
situation and here's the deal in the new
world you have to be perfect
you better be perfect right yeah and so
because everything you do is now
recorded audio video everything be
perfect question everything that's right
that's right um so
um
what i would
strongly encourage you to do
and when i say strongly encourage you
i'm just telling you just like friend to
friend you have to
you gotta go sit down and tell somebody
and i absolutely understand that this
cannot be somebody associated with your
work and if that's the case um i'd
recommend you go find somebody
not insurance figure out find pay the
cash and so there's not a diagnostic
record and sit down with somebody and
say hey uh this thing's starting to wear
on me it's no i'm not okay okay
um and they're gonna walk you through it
i was fortunate i when i had a i was
part of a patrol team and but i had a
every time i'd get out of a messy
situation right like cleaning up a scene
before a mom came home right or
um helping move a body before so and so
showed up before sister got there right
when i was a part of those situations i
was blessed with a supervisor that would
call every time and say how are you
you okay
um
walk me through what you saw and what i
didn't get at the time was there was a
processing going from limbic to frontal
lobe to to
simplify it which is letting my body
know you just experienced some stuff
that was chaos man you just saw guts and
brains and blood and people you just saw
somebody tell their child that their
dads did like you just saw some stuff
you're not supposed to see
and i need to make you make sure you're
with us here that you your body knows
you're safe right now and right now your
body because this is what you do all day
every day and probably
you're pretty lonely guy is that fair
yeah
yeah yeah i just had to admit to that
it's hard is that
it's hard it's hard
and so loneliness
exacerbates what you're experiencing
because your brain needs human beings
and what happens a lot with lawyers it
happens a lot with doctors it happens a
lot with cops is
nobody understands their world because
it's so chaotic it's just such so
different than the norm
that you end up hanging out with only
cops
right yeah then y'all when you're not
working you're talking about working i
can't believe sergeant's moving us to
twelves instead of tens and i can't
right all that's all you do man they're
technicians
yeah dude and we're going from six to
blocks that's ridiculous
and it's just non-stop it never quits
and so you your brain never gets to
watch the sun freaking come up or to try
and even even when yeah oh sorry even
when i try to hang out with like
civilians or non-cops they they always
ask me those stupid questions you know
like yeah
right absolutely it's tiring it is it is
and so
the re-entry program when you meet
people they're going to ask you those
those dumb series of questions the worst
is when veterans come home right did you
kill anybody do you shoot anybody right
and you get that all the time too
it's learning and this is gonna sound
ridiculous the same as when they took
you to marksman classes
you're gonna have to learn a new set of
skills and here's why that sucks because
when we were kids dude they just dropped
us all in a box and said y'all play and
we did they put us on the same kickball
field they're on the same football team
we're on the same whatever and we just
figured it out
and when we're older and we're adults we
don't have that skill set skill set's
gone it's we've lost it
and in the same way you can't just go
pick up and run a marathon right now
uh
you can't just pick up and become best
brothers with somebody you have to it's
annoying and it's long and it's she has
to slog through especially those first
four or five awkward moments and this is
the pot talking to the kettle man i'm a
lonely guy too right i'm having to
practice friendship and that sounds
stupid all right so that's number one
number one is you gotta go talk to
somebody okay you're okay you are ripe
for making a
a a a poor decision
because your your body's trigger is
really really tight right now okay okay
you're gonna not show up you're gonna
miss a call
you're gonna go sit down and all of a
sudden you've been in the restaurant
having a burger on shift for 45 minutes
and you've missed three calls in the car
right it's going to happen right right
or you're going to get on scene and
you're going to snap at somebody who's
just trying to figure out to do the next
how they can do the next right thing
that's my fear it is right and so i'm
telling you your body's getting close
and i want you to go talk to somebody
okay hopefully you have a
sergeant that has passed along how
important this stuff is and that you all
have a culture in your unit of
being open and this stuff not coming
back to bite you during annual reviews
or get you put on a desk for a time
hopefully you've got a
supportive but most police departments
in the country don't have that yet
they're getting there people are moving
there's a lot of shifting and changing
and it's beautiful to see but most
people aren't there yet if it's not go
see somebody
here's part two
how long
have you looked in the mirror and said
i'm not enough
um
your whole damn life yeah since i can
remember
where'd you learn that who told you that
um
it would sometimes uh come from my uh
from my dad and from just uh my uh
childhood time in uh in school okay i
got i got bullied a lot uh i got picked
on for like the dumbest things like the
color of my eyes
or my smile or or something like my
shoes
so
yeah you got picked on and how did you
how did your old man respond to that
um
honestly i wish he would have responded
it seemed like
he him and my mom was still married but
uh i always felt like
he was
far away even though he was here at home
um
most of the time i just remember him
like just
watching tv and just not really caring
about what was going on and if something
would happen he might say something here
and there but
it never felt like he truly
cared and wanted to show me how to
defend myself or
or protect me or anything like that it
just seemed like like i said he was he
was home but he just was not here that's
how i felt he's six feet apart but six
thousand miles away from you right
absolutely yeah hey here's the thing and
i don't have any evidence to back this
up other than just sitting with
countless people over the years
i think there can be as much if not more
trauma
than if he had just left
because when he just left then you got
to deal with it but when they just sit
there
and by the way trauma can be acute it
could be the you walk into the house and
you see part of that person blown all
over that wall that's trauma when you're
hugging a mom who's holding you so tight
because her baby's dead in the next room
that's trauma right
trauma can be acute and
trauma can be what didn't happen
and your dad should have looked at you
in the eye and said i love you son i'm
so sorry this happens give me a hug
right that should have happened and it
didn't now here's the problem
you've spent your life
trying to answer that question
trying to make it so
and when you find somebody as some sort
of conquest
tell me if i'm wrong a few months in
you get bored to quote the great ester
perel you stop feeling alive
this has nothing to do with the women
you're with this has everything to do
with you
and you make a choice to not be alive
and the only thing that gets your heart
rate up
is i'm not getting caught
this new person caught my eye and then
in short order you blow the whole thing
up and then you control all delete and
start the whole cycle over again am i
right
yeah literally you know it's like you've
been like you know me
i do brother i do trust me i do
so listen
the only way to stop cheating is to say
i will never cheat again
okay and what i'll tell you is you're
better than that and the women that
didn't catch you
you
you made them crazy because they knew
there was a disconnection and you know
what they did they thought it was them
and that's not that's wrong it's not
right that's true
right
and they walk around now wondering what
they did why that man couldn't love them
and it probably fulfilled a story that
they've been passing along for their
whole lives right that they've been
they've been spinning around so
and so i am getting on to you stop stop
you know yeah okay
you have a choice in every relationship
and we all do i've been married almost
20 years i've got the same thing
i have to choose how do i remain alive
in this relationship and not alive like
i'm dying my wife's not suffocating me
how do i keep my heart rate up how do i
keep this exciting how do i keep this
fun how do i help meet her needs so she
can help meet my needs and we just get
on the loop like that
not
how can i prop up this shallow thin ego
because nobody ever told me i was worth
the crap
right you see what i'm saying
yeah no it makes it makes a lot of sense
okay
so again
this is looping back to
when you make that call today you're
gonna look you're gonna get on the phone
and you're gonna be brave as i'll get
out like you are right now and you're
gonna call a counselor and they're gonna
say hey what's up and you're gonna say
i'm a police officer
i'm worried about confidentiality
i'm
starting to have signs of of excessive
stress and burnout from my job it's hard
and i need to talk to somebody and
i'm a serial cheater
and i've got it i want to stop
and that's where we're going to go okay
okay
and listen brother
hear me say this because nobody's ever
told you this
i'm a six foot two 200 pound 195 pound
guy okay
i can't shoot as well as you and you
could probably beat me up especially if
you're wearing all your gear and if you
got maze for sure
but listen
i love you
and you're worth being loved back
grateful for the work you do in your
community the crap that you see and you
deal with 24 7 365 that nobody sees and
i'm glad that you don't want to put
yourself in a situation where you're
going to hurt somebody
yeah
and
you're better than the way you're acting
you can do better both and right
yep
exactly thank you so much listen hang on
the line i'm gonna send you a copy of
new book on your past change your future
i'm sending a bunch out to um
the local uh police department here in
my community um
i i think it'll help a lot you've been
through a lot you've seen a lot and then
the question that we all have to ask
ourselves is what do we do next and this
book addresses it i'm gonna give it to
you free of charge i'm grateful for you
man
your new day starts
right now